SECRETARY HOGAN GIDLEY, DARRELL
IS A AND MIKE HUCK WE.
HUCK -- MIKE
HUCKABEE.
AS OUR PRESIDENT IS GETTING
CLOSE TO DOING SOMETHING IN
NORTH KOREA THAT NO OTHER
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN ABLE TO DO.
THERE ARE MANY IN THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA WHO ARE ROOTING FOR HIM TO
FAIL.
HATE IS THEIR DAILY FARE.
THEY HATE HIM SO MUCH, THEY WANT
HIM TO FAIL.
PEACE BE DAMNED.
IF HE DOESN'T GET CREDIT FOR
BEING ONE OF THE SMARTEST, MOST
OF CLEVER AND SUCCESSFUL
NEGOTIATOR PRESIDENTS OF ALL
TIME, THEN WE'LL KNOW FOR SURE
WHAT IT'S ABOUT AND WHO THEY
ARE.
THEY ARE NOT JUST HATERS, AND
THIS IS ABOUT MORE THAN JUST
POLITICS.
THEY ARE ROOTING FOR AMERICA'S
FAILURE, AND THAT IS YOU BE
AMERICAN.
TAKE A LOOK AT HOW THEY REACTED
A FEW WEEKS AGO WHEN THE
PRESIDENT SENT A LETTER TO THE
NORTH KOREAN LEADER CANCELING
THE SUMMIT.
HE BLIND SIDES HIS ALLIES, HE
DOESN'T CONSULT WITH CONGRESS.
AS FAR AS WE KNOW HE DIDN'T
CONSULT WITH HIS OWN NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL.
HE DICTATES THIS BIZARRE
EMBARRASSING LETTER.
>> IT WAS ALWAYS HARD TO BELIEVE
DONALD TRUMP WOULD BE THE FIRST
AMERICAN PRESIDENT EVER TO MEET
A DICTATOR OF NORTH KOREA.
THE EFFORT TO BRING THAT ABOUT
HAS BEEN DISORGANIZED AND NONS
SENSICAL FROM THE START.
>> THE IMPOSSIBLE DREAM TURNED
OUT TO BE AN IMPOSSIBLE DREAM.
PRESIDENT TRUMP CANCELED THE
SUMMIT ACCORDING TO NBC NEWS HE
WAS AFRAID THEY WERE GOING TO
CANCEL AND HE WANTED TO BEAT
THEM TO IT.
JUDGE JEANINE: WE GET THREE
AMERICAN HOSTAGES BACK, THE
PRESIDENT HASN'T LIFTED ANY
SANCTIONS, AND IS PREPARED TIME
POSE NEW DEBILITATING ECONOMIC
SANCTIONS PENDING THE OUTCOME OF
THE SUMMIT.
COMPARE THIS TO OUR LAST FAILURE
OF A PRESIDENT WHO SENT LOVE
LETTERS TO THE AYATOLLAH BEGGING
IRAN TO COME BACK, THEN PAID
THEM OFF WITH TONS OF CASH AND
USE OHS ON PALETTES IN UNMARKED
PLANES.
HOW DOES ONE  * REACT WHEN THE
PRESIDENT PULLS OUT OF THE SUM?
IT HE CRAWLED BACK IN FRONT OF
THE WORLD AND ASKS THE SUMMIT TO
BE BACK ON.
THE THEY HAVE BEEN BUILDING UP
NUCLEAR WEAPONS SINCE BUILT
CLINTON DAYS WHEN HE WANTED TO
GIVE KIM JONG-UN WADS OF CASH.
AND WHEN HE PARADED AROUND
BUILDING ICBMs WHEN OBAMA WAS
PRESIDENT, THEY DID NOTHING,
NOTHING THAT MATTERS.
AS THIS PRESIDENT OPENLY
NEGOTIATES FOR THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF THIS NATION, EVEN
HAS OUR MILITARY STRENGTH AND
ANNOY LATE ISIS.
THIS IS THE COVER OF "THE
ECONOMIST."
THE WRECKING BALL THE PRESIDENT
IS SWING ON IS THE PLANET.
SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER TWEETED
THIS.
WITH ICBMs AND NUCLEAR
WARHEADS IN THE HANDS OF NORTH
KOREA, THE SITUATION IS FAR TOO
DANGEROUS FOR SEAT OF THE PANTS
NEGOTIATING.
CHUCK, IT WAS YOUR PARTY THAT
SECURITY THIS UP.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA HOW MUCH WORK
HAS BEEN DONE.
YOU SIMPLY CAN'T CONNELL
PREBEHIND THE JEAN -- YOU CAN'T
COMPREHEND THE GENIUS OF DONALD
TRUMP UNLESS YOU WERE LOOK FOR A
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION.
BUT THAT WAS BACK THEN.
YOU CAN'T COMPREHEND MIKE
POMPEO.
OUR PRESIDENT HAS NO FEAR.
ACCORDING TO PRESIDENT ABE OF
JAPAN WHO SAID IT BEST.
A MAJOR STEP FORWARD BUSINESS TO
BE TAKEN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, YOU ARE ABOUT
TO MAKE A NEW HISTORY.
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY IS
STRONGLY LOOKING FORWARD FOR THE
UNITED STATES-NORTH KOREAN
SUMMIT TO OPEN DOORS TOWARD
PEACE AND STABILITY OF THE
NORTHEAST I YEAH.
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN LIBERALS
WERE GENEROUS SOULS FIGHTING FOR
THE COMMON MAN TO ASSURE HIS
SUCCESS AND SAFETY.
BUT NOW THEY ARE NOT INTERESTED
IN SUCCESS.
THEY ARE JUST ANGRY.
IN FACT, THEY ARE FURIOUS.
WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO
STEAMROLLS THE ECONOMY TO
HISTORIC HEIGHTS.
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE AT AN
18-YEAR HIGH.
TAX CUTS FOR EVERYONE.
AND UNEMPLOYMENT IS NOT JUST
DOWN, THERE ARE ACTUALLY MORE
JOBS THAN THERE ARE PEOPLE TO
FILL THEM.
DID YOU HEAR WAY JUST SAID?
MORE JOBS AVAILABLE THAN THERE
ARE PEOPLE TO FILL THEM.
AFRICAN-AMERICAN UNEMPLOYMENT IS
AT ITS LOWEST IN THE HISTORY OF
THIS COUNTRY.
AND THEN THE SAME WITH
HISPANICS.
OUR BUSINESSES WILL BE ABLE TO
COMPETE AGAIN AS WE GET OUR MOJO
BACK ON THE WORLD STAGE.
TAKE A LOOK AGENT THESE PICTURES
FROM THE G-7.
OUR PRESIDENT TONIGHT MIDDLE OF
EVERY PHOTO.
THE MAN IS CENTER STAGE.
WORLD LEADERS ARE ALL OVER HIM.
THE QUESTIONS ARE TO HIM.
HE IS DOMINATING THE G-7.
AMERICA IS BACK, FOLKS.
THE TRUTH, HOWEVER, IS A FAR CRY
FROM WHAT STUMBLING NANCY SAID
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO.
>> THIS TAKES PREPARATION.
THIS TAKES KNOWLEDGE.
THIS TAKES JUDGMENT.
AND CLEARLY IT TAKES PREPARATION
WHICH THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T MAKE.
IT'S CLEAR HE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
HE WAS GETTING INTO.
JUDGE JEANINE: SWEETHEART, AS
THE PRESIDENT SAID HIMSELF, HE
HAS BEEN PREPARING FOR HIS HIS
WHOLE LIFE.
AND NOT PREPARED?
YOU CAN'T BEGIN TO COMPREHEND
THE SUCCESS AND BENEFITS WE'LL
REAP FROM THE MEETING WE HAVE
BEEN WAITING A LIFETIME FOR.
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN AMERICA
CELEBRATED SUCCESSES TOGETHER.
WE WE CAME OUT WITH OUR KIDS ON
THE STREETS WITH PARADES, WAVING
OUR FLAGS AND TEACHING OUR
CHILDREN THE IMPORTANCE OF
PATRIOTISM.
DONALD TRUMP IS BRINGING AMERICA
BACK IN FRONT OUR EYES.
AND IT'S TIME FOR THE
UN-AMERICAN HATERS TO GET ON
BOARD.
AND THAT'S MY OPEN.